the Joe Rogan experience how doesn't
work at me oh right what kind of pot any
I bet the pot we have a work on you up
to 50 I've done 55 milligrams edibles
that's ridiculously low I'd do 200 every
time we go to the airport yes okay but
I'm like Joey mm all right maybe I just
haven't got my game yet you can't say
pot doesn't work on you okay but I I so
far have been unable to respond to it
really yep mm-hmm in smoking it or
eating it or both both Jamie is with you
with the eating he's got some weird
genetic disorder that doesn't it doesn't
work with him like edible he can take a
thousand edibles and just hang around
people yeah but so that's a thing like
people are immune some people are going
to see it this not some people get
withdrawals to you know I've talked to
people that get actual physical
withdrawals from marijuana and I used to
be really skeptical about that but these
these are people that I actually trust
and they're like wow I would you know
when they would go on tour like if they
have to go places and they didn't have
pot they would get literally they'd get
shaky they feel weird and then they
realize that oh this is my body's
withdrawing from THC apparently it's
very rare but common enough so that it's
in the literature they really have
documented people that have like a
physical response to withdrawing from
marijuana yeah I mean I'm looking
forward to more research being done on
this stuff anyway yes yeah we're headed
there yes but then Trump recently said
something about trying to I know I'm
surprised he was comparing the way they
handled drug dealers in China with a
swift fair trial
yeah did he was he saying Singapore no
but but that's how they do in Singapore
with swift fair trial and the death
penalty is what he said there's a
resurgence of this in Asia you see it in
the Philippines as well so yeah thirty's
has this extrajudicial drug war that
he's been launching so it's I understand
the concern with the plight I understand
that people are really worried that
people getting it
to drugs ruin their lives the devastates
families people dying of overdoses from
fentanyl and all these different hazards
that are associated with drug use and
drug drug dealing I understand that but
this sort of archaic way of handling it
death penalty talk in 2020 I know it's
in one country completely decriminalized
all drugs right was a Portugal yeah yeah
the results low everything lower
incidence of HIV infection lower drug
addiction lowered overdoses lower
everything lower crime rate I just don't
it's just messy it's not like if there
was one thing you could do okay if we do
this thing then no one gets addicted to
drugs and no one dies from overdoses
well then you do that thing but there is
no legalization no one would see they
certainly would though people definitely
will die of overdoses if you make drugs
legal across the board the one thing
that you do that's good is you stop all
the flow of money into illegal drug
sales so all the people that are selling
draw or most of it at least
all the cartel money all that stuff goes
away because the cartels are making
billions and billions of dollars selling
to the United States and other countries
in itself - and they're doing it because
it's illegal because it's a business
they can capitalize on that American
businesses are not capitalizing on it
and violence goes down - I'm assuming
there's a correlation there's if you go
back to what happened in the United
States during Prohibition what it did is
pop up organized crime it propped up
organized crime and a pretty spectacular
way and it was because there was a
massive amount of money to be made
selling alcohol the desire for alcohol
didn't go away the legality of it went
away so illegal sales went through the
roof and the people that were selling it
were criminals
[Applause]